thank you Jason wants to share something
with the class oh
I wanted to share that what did I want
to share
huh
I wanted to ask
um Anthony
uh what was his earlier I wanted to ask
um what was the point that you wanted to
you you were committed into JK from um
oh that was a serious question yeah
we're gonna say that for later okay
you thought that's what you wanted me no
I didn't think that was what you're
gonna say
what that's what okay then we're gonna
switch we're gonna switch now now we're
gonna answer that question now
[Music]
welcome to another amazing episode of
the careful boys where we today have the
amazing Jason Cheney in the building wow
Jason Jenny he's pretty great
um maybe a slightly better grammar
rephrase that question you know what I
say it the way I want it yeah okay hey
[ __ ] that guy you say how you want to
say yeah
wait wait wait
go ahead and say it the way you want to
say it yeah man
man [ __ ] you man
no no no
it's huge over there no yeah sucked in
stop cameras these [ __ ] am I
right no I'm talking about you [ __ ]
one of them and they're [ __ ] moms all
right nobody over there now go and ask
that really harmful wholesome question
again no I was really curious because
um earlier I was asked that's really
rude for them to keep on bothering us
like that while you're talking go ahead
thank you
you bulldozed me
well what is the because earlier I was
curious because you said you created
your schedule and uh with uh JK around
it you know and I was just wondering
what was the point is there a point or
is there a time period and what are the
things that you
um that affected you for you to decide
to wanted to commit to just kidding news
that's right that's right yeah that was
a very good question we were talking
about this during lunch what do you mean
that's right I just asked you this
so don't act like you didn't hear this
30 seconds ago that's all all right just
answer it like a normal person all these
[ __ ] [ __ ] who [ __ ] aren't
paying attention he just asked this what
do you mean that's right a minute ago I
think schizophrenic dude all right
that's right that's right
honestly he's zany
watch out lady guy
okay so uh was there a point in a time
let me rephrase this in a way that these
[ __ ] understand no they understand uh
uh a point in time where I uh I decided
to dedicate more of my time to JK and
stuff that we were asking
yeah more of a time yeah okay yeah
um I think uh number one uh I've always
loved my time here at Jacob sitting here
many times before I feel like especially
with whatever few experience I have on
like social media most people know me
for dancing but the thing is the way I
like as a choreographer and a Creator
I'm always dancing to these like
ethereal songs or like deeper songs and
that's a real true expression myself a
little schizophrenic like Nick said I
definitely have a side that I don't know
how to express in words maybe more
sensitive more whatever and I end up
like expressing that through my dance so
if people didn't know who I was as a
person at all they only judged me off my
dance I probably seem like a really
quiet deep thinker uh like sad and emo
kind of yeah sad emo
yeah kind of a [ __ ] you know but that's
true that really is true that's a part
of my soul that needs expressing in that
way but then there's also this other
side where I get to kind of just you
know be a little bit more myself and
talk freely and be an idiot where the
[ __ ] it is that I am here
um and that's like also I've learned to
realize just healthy and fun for me too
just like a fun part of my life
um but the thing is when I would have
those experiences here on JK it would
always be like few and far in between it
would be like as guests right it so if I
was like teaching or prioritizing
whatever my dance career was if I had a
pocket of time I would come down here to
guess and I'll you know people like
borrow Joe would invite me here and just
like you once in a while just come and
I'd be like man this is really [ __ ]
fun but I didn't think that that was
like me or my thing right much like I'm
pretty sure all of us and I'm relating
to it mainly like Nick and Ryan because
I think we're all like newer regulars
right see the nodding see the nodding
we're like newer regulars on the spot
but because like we do like quote
unquote other things but having this
kind of platform
was just really fun and a different kind
of way for us to like find ourselves you
know what I'm saying so when it came to
like the pandemic and then like all the
[ __ ] like the dance jobs that I had
the Studios closing the traveling and
teaching all that stuff went kind of
down the drain suddenly had all this
free times and I was desperate and I was
poor so I was like oh man JK you
and that's where I am now JK I'll give
him a chance finally yeah yeah that's
our desperate and poor I guess I'll go
with you guys wow that was a good night
that took a turn that's very heartfelt
thank you yeah how does that make you
feel for hearing that it makes me feel
very uh appreciated
no but but but to be true though there
was a time where suddenly um without
traveling stuff like that uh I was home
and before I always wanted to be a part
of JK in a different way you know what I
mean just like being like I love my time
here I get to be a different but honest
version of myself but it was just at a
guest level what's up with the orgy
the thing is it is really hard to search
but it is hard sometimes to say like the
real thing because it's on the thing but
I know what you mean the same like a
another true self in another party oh I
was scared I thought you were going
deeper into an orgy thing and I was like
oh man oh we will but yeah no um so so
then once you know not having like a
bunch of like other dance stuff and
stuff and just like having more time at
home I think I was always 60 out of the
country you know before the pandemic and
then suddenly I'm like stuck in the
country in a different way but the cool
thing is like these guys didn't care
about kovid they're like [ __ ] you can
spit in my mouth right that's what I
said and I caught it like five times
[Laughter]
we don't give a [ __ ] you get spit in my
mouth and I remember being like dude
these guys love me oh that's all they
accept me and then they're just really
into that I know I love you too
organically I got to you know just
because we were all here it became more
regular and I was like hey I'm I'm here
and I just like I think I've always been
really forward with people like bar and
Joe I've been really comfortable with my
relationship with Bart and I was just
like be honest with him you know I'd be
like hey I'm here if you guys like want
me to stay around I would love to and
then he was just super cool about it he
was like Yo dude like yeah for sure him
and Joe they just walked me in as like
you know they I became a regular so you
will uh and then there was this time
that they just needed more hosts and a
lot of like that you know responsibility
fell on Steve because he was kind of
just like this interim host and they're
just like hey uh you know like Steve you
got to do this blah blah and he was like
I don't know I'm just trying to fill in
and I was sitting there and I was like
uh I've kind of host stuff from time to
time I think I'll be pretty good and
then they were just always open every
single time I like uh kind of like asked
for something they were always open and
then because of that I just feel like my
relationship here and my place here just
like they just accepted it and they just
let me be myself and that's why I was
like you know I just want to dedicate
myself to a place that like is open to
me except me for who I am all the time
allows me to express myself in a way
that all my other platforms don't allow
me to do that you know what I mean you
know I was talking sorry to divert the
attention to care bulldozing me right
now
oh I was talking to Ken and he was
saying the same thing it's like it's
really I feel like more rare nowadays to
find like a group of people that uh that
just has what you just said like
accepting and trusting each other with
their professionalism and their love and
their work and it's hard to find that
and that's really cool I think I think
it's a privilege to have that for sure
you know when you collaborate or you
work with a lot of different like
different businesses or groups of people
it's way more rare than you think to
just have like a group of people that
can co-exist professionally yeah but
still transcend that personal boundary
and be like oh I actually trust these
people will consider my friends and am
down to do things outside of business
you know what I'm saying so this just
happened to be a pocket and a family
that made sense and it was easy for me I
think you know what I mean to dive into
a place like this but I think that's a
great question to ask even people like
you know Nick and Rick who are also I
would love to hear all but even Kathleen
Colleen Colleen Colleen I'm so sorry
[Laughter]
yeah no I know but it's just I don't I'm
so bad with the [ __ ] well it's a
unique name too it is a unique one and I
really like this is Jason you guys I
remember the dad the dad and the mom
thing I remember stories more than like
I'm really bad with remembering a lot
like words I apologize no no no no
apology does a little more actually look
hey Nick
Steve may not be here but this is still
the uh believe all women's side right so
you should believe me when I say hey I
got this
let's apologize immediately disagree
with what's happening right now by the
way I'm Anthony
I know oh okay wait guys wait wait it
like turn such a Sentimental moment into
just JK Foolery hey he'll say anything
to avoid it being asked the question
I'm curious about you just open up once
dude I'll be [ __ ] dude I'm always
honest okay okay say something that's
going you guys asked me to start doing
JK are you angry already hold on hold
when you guys ask me when you guys ask
me to start doing JK I go
this must be a sinking ship dude
I'm gonna be rough
but but Ryan May is bringing the [ __ ]
numbers back up he's bringing members
though back up but it's true though but
honestly see like the first time
David asked me to do a podcast right on
his podcast yeah I was I was like
freaking out I was like Jesus Christ he
must not know anybody
I was like why is he asking me to go no
I was like I was like David Last Resort
because everything good you know what I
mean so he kept asking me to go on and
then this dude eventually asked me like
hey you want to come do JK and I was
like
all right dude if you if you need me to
go on but um I was kind of I was like
super nervous I didn't know what to
expect
um and I thought I was like they must be
running out of [ __ ] gas they can't
get anybody did you already have your
MMA podcasting yeah we were doing that
at the beginning of the uh of that
pandemic um and it was around the time
you asked me to go on JK was it before a
pandemic wait but did you when you asked
him to call on JK did you ask him as a
guest or did you just sit right in that
chair he just asked me to come here I
remember texting the right Nick when you
asked him that's what it was I messed up
and he was like oh my goodness he did he
did he did ask me in person so I was
like all right okay automatically
promoted some of us had to go through
the guests and get in trial by fire he
went straight to the BART table no but
but it was stable some people that's the
real table Yeah that's the believe all
women table that's right I don't believe
it but but when you ask why am I not on
that side I clearly believe it why not
what are you saying about yourself by
default but I think you guys would
slowly ask me to come back every now and
then and then and then all of a sudden
you guys just kept asking me to come
back and I was like all right [ __ ] okay
and I was like kind of skeptical I was
like all right we'll see because I
didn't think I was I'm gonna be honest I
don't think I was that good when I came
on because it was weird because now I
think differently on the [ __ ] well I
definitely feel more comfortable talking
talking but I still I still feel like
I'm [ __ ] dude you're top six here top
six I'm kind of I'm trying to get over
can I'm still below can dude and he's
not even on camera
um but no uh when you guys started
asking me to come on I just uh was
really unsure I was definitely unsure
but I really like being here with you
guys this is a lot of fun yeah bring it
back why are you pointing me like that
see but he's asking you he's asking what
was the moment where you're like I'm
committing well I didn't ask that you
just oh the moment the moment I
committed was uh
was when you guys asked me to be a
regular yeah when you guys asked me and
I was like
all right you sure Nick's like they must
be running out of regulars but look I'm
gonna be honest like that's when it was
in my head I was like [ __ ] like all
right if you guys want me to keep coming
back I'll come back you know because I I
do hold you guys very high regard I do
like I I've said this before about Joe
and Bart and even David too just as far
as like you guys you guys have helped me
out so much and you know anytime I could
be of use to you I'll always try my best
you know but at the same time being with
everybody here getting to meet everybody
has been really [ __ ] cool and it's
like dude the fact that I can call this
work at some point is crazy you know
like that that is pretty cool it's nuts
dude the fact that I can come over here
and you know shoot the [ __ ] with you
guys and say slanderous things about
everything
dude if I say this at work I do say the
stuff at work anyway but my job is
different but as far as being able to
say this out loud onto a platform that
has a good amount of people watching is
correct I still never in my life would
ever believe I would be doing this so it
is pretty fun cool I hope you take it
seriously someday
hope you open up finally explain
yourself
no but I'm very thankful to be here I'm
I'm as much as I joke and I always do
all that it's it's really cool to be a
part of this happy to have you man hey
[ __ ] you dude
I'm complimented I hope you start
hanging out with us outside the office I
want to hang out with you guys more it
just you know sometimes it just eight
hours is enough
I also wonder about
I don't you want to ask
barters when did you choose to commit to
this no where did you get out of no I
was curious about Ryan and also Colleen
I uh for me I think um I mean I've
always watched JK like the same time
that I started my dance stuff seriously
was the same time that JK kind of
started their stuff so it was like neck
and neck you kind of not that we're
competing but we're working together for
independent Asian representation in
media so it was a very like easy thing
to be an alliance unspoken to be like
wow these guys are you know helping push
this whole thing forward
so I always had the respect for that and
also once new started is when it really
started just like watching it all the
time and just having it on just like a
lot of people might do just as you get
ready or when you're doing other things
you just kind of have it on and it was
great and then the first time um I done
like a sketch or two with them in the
past but then once I came onto news and
I did a full day I remember thinking
dude for hours we just hung out and I
built such a good rapport with him and
I'm just never gonna [ __ ] see them
again that's a weird thing to do you
know like what that's it and then I
remember I wanted to come back but I
didn't want to be weird and go hey you
guys need a extra seat somewhere or
anything but like bus to Anthony yeah so
I would just wait for him to hit me up
which hit me up just one video just one
[ __ ] video
you're even joking about something that
I know you like I love I love that in
you I love that one [ __ ] that secret
I love that it's about Ryan right now
put it back to you please fine please
Ryan
you'll save me you win every thing
just give me this one I think that's the
thing that meant a lot to me is like
I've always you know I've been friends
with a few of them I never got really
close to them until we started doing
this and then I was like I just
genuinely enjoy it that's the main thing
underneath all of it underneath all the
work underneath however long it takes
[ __ ] here I just like it and also at
the same time I appreciate the you know
like it's maybe JK's not as Asian
Centric it doesn't have to be but I love
the idea that
um it's an option out there because I
feel like in the beginning whoever was
just doing stuff on Independent Media
that was Asian that's all you got now
you can not like us and that's okay
because there's so many [ __ ] choices
out there and I think that's really cool
to still be around and just be
authentically what we are rather than
try to cater to what people want to see
us do
which is important to me because I think
it took a lot of time for independent
Asian creators to achieve that to be
like hey guess what there's enough of us
now that we don't have to [ __ ] be the
exact type of Asian that you want it's
like hey this is just our genuine
[ __ ] lives we're gonna say [ __ ] that
might not be agreeable we're gonna like
have views that might be expired to
somebody but that's authentically who
these people are and I think that's an
important thing in a very rare platform
to have real quick I want that that's my
answer too right right what if they
subscribe to patreon we'll suck your
dick and say anything yeah yeah as a
white female that's also my answer yeah
were you always in editing because I
just want to also piggyback off of what
Nick was saying like the clips are
[ __ ] amazing like the editing I did
management for social media for other
people in the past yeah yeah similar
yeah you know I see the nonchalance
already kind of coming off your lips but
dude did you always edit at a superb
level were you always the best at
marketing I don't know that it's you've
heard courses at University for this
year it does help that I'm editing off
an edit like it's Canon and his boys are
doing the initial edit and then I'm just
condensing it for short form so it's
really yeah I'm just I'm just stealing
their Thunder
no it's it's just you know it's just
based off of what what I feel like we
would want to see ourselves that's it
you know
um I mean I'm I'm only here because Ryan
introduced me to to you guys and he was
like
you should really be on you're hilarious
and I was like please don't tell them
that
no I didn't I said they wanted some like
a white supremacy female so I said
Colleen should represent that so white
power after I just advocated for the
Asian people
right this all makes sense so what
you're telling me yeah I did suggest you
just because I'm like like my my
friendship with her it's like she's a
person that I've always known I can say
whatever and she'll understand the tone
of anything I say she'll know if I'm
being serious if I mean sarcastic it's
all like she's just really good at
knowing that so I'm like what better
person for something like this than
somebody who can tell when we're just
[ __ ] around and we don't really want
everyone to die it's very true Ryan's
going through his head he's like we're
gonna say [ __ ] up [ __ ] Who's down ah
Colleen a white power woman
like a woman the first I've ever been
laid bold as that white power woman you
can have it if you want you could be
dangerous you could be a power woman you
know it's kind of catchy yeah
just do that screw Lionheart nobody ever
remembers that name anymore she's just
easy to talk to and I didn't I didn't
know that when she was on here she would
do as well as like you know people
really took to her like really quickly
and it's yeah why am I still here Bart
because you're awesome oh thanks see so
we circled back to the sentimental part
this is good somebody make a joke it's
awkward no you're really good tip your
hat I'm I'm actually really appreciative
of everyone here [ __ ] you yeah thank you
oh there it is thank you
I was just busting a Nick yeah he's
about to put us all in order you're like
[Applause]
it's about all of us later bro we don't
want to hear it I don't want to hear it
turn it off let's hear some compliments
man no I'm really I'm really really
appreciative everyone here because
um I think we've what we were trying to
do like me and Joe was trying to create
like a safe space for just content in
general yeah I started off with a lot of
the Asian American stuff and it's cool
to see all these creators now where like
not everyone has to have the same voice
and also as you know like during like
that whole
um Asian American movement phase like I
would say from like the 2010s like the
2015s as we start doing shows our shows
like people that showed up became more
and more diverse and then it was more
about like people that thought the same
rather than people that look the same
you know and so in this group like we
all we've always wanted to create like a
safe space because like when you and
your friends like your brother and
sister or your like boys and your girls
or whatever when you guys are [ __ ]
around and you say like crazy [ __ ] no
one is canceling each other in the group
because you guys are just having a good
time so for us like the chemistry the
dynamic of like recreating that and then
so that we can kind of bring and expand
this camaraderie to the rest of the
world was like so so important to us so
we slowly moved away from the hall being
like super Asian American Centric we
still cover a little bit of those topics
just because it can't help the way I
look you know and uh we so we we touch
on those but we're really trying to
expand and overall we're just trying to
bring like-minded individuals in here
and so for people to like have the same
sense of humor and and and talk and Vibe
and be able to kind of create like
I think this room should actually be
called The Writer's room because the
only other place that I've ever felt
this safe is in writer's room so when
you go inside of like the actual Riders
when you lock the door people could say
the craziest [ __ ] because we know this
is the most insane brainstorm session
that we're ever gonna have no idea is a
bad idea you just say it and if it if it
like rings a bell in the room that's
what's going down on paper you know
right and so in here we felt like that's
what it was supposed to be and so over
the years I think like you know we we've
always wanted to keep that as The
Guiding Light as a North star and it's
just like really really cool that
um as where me and Joe are really trying
to re-emphasize the whole direction of
the channel that all of you guys came
into our lives and were able to continue
this journey so thank you guys so much
thank you I'm just trying to I'm just
trying to think of Colleen's perspective
as Bart's trying to like be serious
about like you know it wasn't about how
we all look it's about how we all think
I feel included
thank you so much I feel included she's
Chinese too yeah
32.1 it changes every time and somehow
people keep believing me